[موسيقى]
من الأقمار الصناعية للطائرات بدون طيار التي تعمل بتقنية
الفضاء وحتى الطائرات الكهربائية
تعتقد أن الطائرات النفاثة هي الطائرة النفاثة الكهربائية الوحيدة
للإقلاع والهبوط العمودي
التي تستخدم الدفع النفاث بدلاً
من المراوح ،
وهي الأسماء الأكبر في التكنولوجيا والابتكار ، مما
يجعل وجودها معروفًا في
المملكة العربية السعودية لأنها تتطلع إلى
الشرق الأوسط كحدود تالية
للنمو ، الخبر الكبير في مبادرة الاستثمار المستقبلية
هو الإعلان عن أن 44
شركة متعددة الجنسيات من سيمنز إلى
بيبسيكو وبيكر هيوز ستنقل
مقارها الإقليمية في الشرق الأوسط إلى
المملكة ، ويقول الكثيرون إن هذه الخطوة تدور
حول الفرص التكنولوجية في  المملكة العربية السعودية
هذه الشركات متعددة الجنسيات لديها خيارات
فهي مثل أي شخص آخر
وفي نهاية اليوم سوف يتخذون
خيارهم بناءً على قيمة الأعمال
والنمو ، ليس لدينا بالطبع أي شخص
قادم.
بيع عرض القيمة الخاص بنا
وهذا العرض يشمل القيمة
المعرفية الأولى في العالم
مدينة
لذلك عندما نذهب إلى مدينة معرفية ، فإننا
نعني مدينة تنبؤية تكون
استباقية بمعنى آخر يزيل
الاحتكاك من حياتك
في القمة ، وقع النيون صفقة مع
شبكة واحدة مقابل 200 مليون دولار أمريكي ،
مهمتنا هي توصيل
غير المتصلين و  الطريقة التي نفعل بها ذلك
هي أننا نستخدم تكنولوجيا الأقمار الصناعية
لنشر اتصال النطاق العريض منخفض الكمون في
جميع أنحاء العالم ،
يقول ممثلو العالم إن اتفاقية المشروع المشترك
بين شركة نيوم للتكنولوجيا والشركة
الفرعية الرقمية ستجلب الاتصال عبر الأقمار الصناعية
إلى المملكة العربية السعودية ودول
الشرق الأوسط وشرق أفريقيا
المجاورة.
نرى أنه فقط من
neom انتقل من رؤية في شرائح PowerPoint
إلى الكيانات
التي تنفذ للعملاء الذين يثمنون عرض القيمة الخاص بنا
إذا نظرت حول العالم
لماذا يأتون إلى هذه المنطقة ،
فلنوضح أنهم يأتون إلى هذه المنطقة
نظرًا لأن 60 بالمائة من السعوديين تقل
أعمارهم عن 35 عامًا ،
فإن معدل نمو اختراق السحابة في
هذه المنطقة يبلغ 40 بالمائة ك  aggar عامًا
بعد عام ، إنها قصة نمو
وليست منطقة الخليج فقط في
الاستفادة من آفاق التكنولوجيا الجديدة من 2019
إلى 2021 ، فقد انتقلت تركيا من صفر وحيد القرن
إلى خمس شركات ناشئة خاصة تقدر قيمتها بأكثر
من مليار دولار أمريكي بشكل رئيسي في
قطاع التكنولوجيا بما في ذلك خدمات التسوق عبر الإنترنت
مثل  الاتجاه الذي
وصل مؤخرًا إلى قيمة 10 مليار دولار أمريكي
بعد استثمار بقيمة 350 مليون دولار أمريكي من
قبل علي بابا
حيث تشهد المنطقة
تغيرًا كبيرًا ، يقدم الشرق الأوسط
وفرة من الفرص في الابتكار من
خلال التكنولوجيا.